[Aplausos]
[Música]
aquí se escuchan también los Ecos de
quienes anónimamente se han levantado
contra la opresión
defendiendo los derechos humanos
exigiendo verdad justicia reparación y
garantía de no repetición tenemos que
abrazarnos como sociedad volver a
querernos volver a
sonreír
queridos amigos de visual politic en los
últimos años en la política de América
Latina ha destacado un concepto por
encima de todos los demás la idea del
bloqueo legislativo estoy seguro de que
no os pilla de nuevas es la nueva
tendencia política de la región los
presidentes llegan al poder pero sin
controlar los parlamentos por ejemplo
recordáis Por qué Guillermo lao convocó
elecciones anticipadas efectivamente lo
hizo porque la oposición que tenía
mayoría en el congreso bloqueaba
prácticamente todas las acciones de
gobierno recordáis qué fue lo que estuvo
detrás del incompetente y desastroso
intento de golpe de estado de Pedro
Castillo en Perú Exacto el congreso
pasaba olímpicamente del presidente en
poco más de año y medio 70 proyectos de
ley enviados por el gobierno fueron
completamente marginados por el congreso
las situaciones de Ecuador y del Perú
fueron extremas pero en general el
bloqueo político se ha convertido en una
situación convencional en América Latina
es algo que en cierta forma también está
empezando a sufrir Lula en Brasil y en
Argentina de imponerse mi ley a masa y
llegar a la presidencia es muy probable
que ocurra tres cuartas partes de lo
mismo y eso no es todo sabéis quién más
está sufriendo esta situación pues nada
más y nada menos que el presidente de la
que seguramente haya sido la economía
más próspera de América Latina en los
últimos años os estamos hablando por
supuesto del chileno Gabriel boric el
protagonista de este
vídeo
queridos amigos un año y medio después
de que borich asumiera el poder en Chile
muchos ya dictaron sentencia su
presidencia está ausente por no decir
que para los suyos ha resultado muy
decepcionante claro que mentirías si os
dijéramos que la única razón de su pobre
desempeño ha sido el bloqueo legislativo
la realidad es que borich no ha sabido
tomar bien el pulso a Chile o mejor
dicho a los chilenos que le dieron su
apoyo algo que sea reflejado
perfectamente con la caída en picado de
su aprobación como presidente cadem
aprobación de bori cae a 28 por y un 86
por cree que hay corrupción en caso
democracia viva y por si fuera poco
borich también está sufriendo un
paulatino incremento de la criminalidad
en Chile tal y como ha ocurrido en
Ecuador Aunque eso sí a velocidad mucho
más lenta al menos por ahora por eso
ante toda esta situación en visual
politic nos hemos hecho unas cuantas
preguntas qué expectativas generó
Gabriel Boris con su llegada a la
presidencia por qué muchos dicen que su
mandato está siendo un completo fracaso
es realmente así cómo está afrontando la
decreciente inseguridad que se vive en
el país hoy vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de
historia pero antes dadme solo un
segundo ya que hablamos de problemas y
de crisis sabíais que nos estamos
quedando sin aviones o mejor dicho que
no hay aves suficientes y que eso hará
subir probablemente los precios de los
billetes no es ninguna exageración en el
mundo no hay aviones suficientes para
atender toda la demanda y los pilotos
también comienzan a escasear esto es
algo que está empezando a ser un
problema y que ha obligado a una
compañía como luth hansa a poner de
nuevo en marcha los airbus a380 que
había retirado Pues bien os cuento todos
los detalles en uno de los últimos
vídeos de si lo hubiera sabido el canal
de información financiera de muto
activos con el que participamos os dejo
toda la información y el enlace en la
descripción y ahora sí
continuemos a la izquierda de la
izquierda A diferencia de Colombia lo de
tener presidencias de izquierdas no es
algo inusual en Chile tras el fin de la
dictadura de pinochet en
1990 Ricardo lagos y Michel bachelet
ambos líderes de izquierdas ostentaron
El Poder desde el año 2000 hasta hasta
el 2010 y luego bachelet repitió
nuevamente en una segunda presidencia de
2014 a 2018 sin embargo en estos más de
30 años de democracia chile nunca había
tenido a un presidente como morich un
presidente que presuntamente iba a
situarse mucho más a la izquierda que
los anteriores un paso Más allá de lo
que podríamos considerar la social
democracia típica Pero cómo consiguió
entonces un candidato como borich tanto
apoyo como para alcanzar la presidencia
en un país como chile Pues bien para
entenderlo tenemos que remontarnos a
2019 el año del famoso estallido
social tras la grave desaceleración
económica que se produjo al final del
mandato de bachelet los años 2016 y 2017
Sebastián Piñera que ya había sido
presidente de Chile entre 2010 y 2014
consiguió regresar al palacio de la
moneda sin embargo su presidencia no iba
a ser nada fácil la crisis que tuvo que
enfrentar durante su primer mandato
quedó en nada Comparado con el estallido
social que se produjo durante su segunda
presidencia en octubre del año 2019 tras
anunciarse un aumento de los precios del
transporte público en la capital
Santiago se desataron protestas masivas
por supuesto el precio del transporte
fue solo una excusa de repente decenas y
decenas y decenas de miles de chilenos
comenzaron a protestar contra la
excesiva desigualdad social que en su
opinión existía en el
país y eso que chile había hecho grandes
avances reduciendo la desigualdad fijaos
el país No solo experimentó una
importante reducción de la desigualdad
hasta el 2019 sino que incluso la
población que se encontraba bajo la
línea de pobreza cayó de en torno a un
40% en 1999 a un 9% en 2018 da igual a
pesar de los datos y la Clara mejora de
las condiciones de vida que esto
reflejaban una buena parte de la
población chilena tenía una percepción
totalmente diferente lo que contribuyó a
que las protestas se gener realizaran Y
terminaran convirtiéndose prácticamente
en un levantamiento
civil no obstante al final el presidente
Piñera logró calmar las aguas cediendo
al Principal reclamo de los
manifestantes el presidente de Chile
firma la ley para un referéndum
constitucional tras más de dos meses de
protestas pero por mucho que cediera con
este tema la realidad es que la
aprobación de Piñera estaba bajo mínimos
y en cierto modo no es para menos su
papel no gustó a práctica ente nadie
unos le culparon por no saber contener
la marea y otros por emplear una fuerza
excesiva pensad que durante las
protestas los carabineros se vieron
completamente desbordados lo que por
ejemplo terminó provocando actuaciones
más o menos erráticas que se saldaron
con 34 manifestantes fallecidos entre
octubre de 2019 y marzo de 2020 y fue
justo en este contexto de enorme tensión
social con un gobierno que además estaba
implosion políticamente cuando nuestro
protagonista de hoy se posicionó como el
principal líder de la izquierda enojada
Que alimentaba las protestas borich
comenzó entonces a liderar la voz de la
oposición Gabriel bori que comenzó su
actividad política como líder
estudiantil atacando duramente a los
gobiernos de la reinstaurar Democracia
consiguió en 2014 convertirse en
diputado nacional desde el primer
momento sus tatuajes y maps llamaron la
atención de todo el congreso Y por
supuesto también de la sociedad chilena
y y eso no es todo su encuentro con
Ricardo Palma Salamanca un
exparlamentario comunista acusado del
asesinato de Jaime Guzmán uno de los
autores de la Constitución de 1980
también fue tremendamente polémico pero
no fue hasta las protestas de 2019 y sus
duras críticas a las fuerzas del orden
público cuando su figura se vio
catapultada lo que le permitió
posicionarse como el primer candidato de
la izquierda en las elecciones de 2021
borik prometió entonces medidas como la
revisión de los acuerdos de libre
comercio o la imposición a todas las
empresas ya fueran públicas o privadas
de la entrega del 50% de los puestos
directivos a los trabajadores al final
no obstante se vio obligado a moderar su
programa claramente marxista para poder
vencer al conservador José Antonio cast
en segunda vuelta algo que finalmente
consiguió gracias sobre todo al voto
joven y
femenino pese a todo cuando borich
asumió el cargo prometió muchas cosas la
nueva constitución una fuerte expansión
del tamaño del Estado un enorme
incremento de impuestos equivalente al
8% del pib en dos mandatos transporte
público gratuito sanidad universal y
gratuita y Así podríamos seguir con una
larga lista de compromisos borich
parecía querer volver sobre los pasos de
Salvador Allende algo que quedó muy
claro en su primer discurso como
presidente
pronosticar Hace casi 50 años Salvador
Allende estamos de nuevo compatriotas
abriendo las grandes Alamedas
por donde pase el hombre libre el hombre
y la mujer libre para construir una
sociedad mejor seguimos viva chile ahora
la pregunta es está logrando borich
materializar alguna de sus grandes
promesas Cómo ha recibido el pueblo
chileno la presidencia de boric Pues
bien veámoslo
[Música]
noqueado en primera
ronda
como ya os hemos contado al principio
del vídeo la presidencia de borich ha
estado hasta el momento casi
absolutamente bloqueada por una razón
las matemáticas parlamentarias no están
de su parte y es que veréis la coalición
de gobierno de borich formada por su
propia coalición llamada apruebo
dignidad y la coalición socialismo
democrático cuentan en total con 67
diputados sabéis Con cuántos cuenta la
oposición con 70 es decir tres más y en
el senado el panorama es aún peor allí
para el gobierno porque la oposición de
derecha es aún más fuerte por eso el
impulso de las reformas que tenía en
mente se le ha complicado y mucho a
boric el bloqueo parlamentario
prácticamente ha bloqueado su
presidencia y eso está ocurriendo además
con una oposición que cada vez es más
popular El caso es que esta situación ha
afectado incluso a la ley más importante
de su gobierno la reforma tributaria
[Música]
la reforma tributaria presentada por el
ministro de hacienda de boric Mario
Marcel pretende aumentar la recaudación
4,1 puntos del pib de manera gradual a
lo largo de la legislatura esperaba con
ello poder financiar buena parte de su
programa político para conseguir ese
objetivo de recaudación se preveía la
creación de varios impuestos por ejemplo
un impuesto a la riqueza con dos tramos
uno de un 1% y otro de un 1,8 por que
grababa el ahorro a todos los residentes
en Chile con patrimonios superiores a
los 5 millones dó o también un impuesto
a la salida de patrimonios de un 5%
sobre los contribuyentes que cambiará su
residencia tributaria además la reforma
también incluía mayores competencias
para el servicio de impuestos internos y
la creación de la figura del denunciante
anónimo que resultaba especialmente
problemática por crear un incentivo
monetario para los propios denunciantes
y claro semejante reforma choca
frontalmente con la posición política de
la oposición el resultado pues os lo
podde podéis imaginar chile rechazó la
reforma tributaria impacta al gobierno a
un año del inicio del gobierno del
presidente de Chile Gabriel boric las
esperanzas por un cambio profundo
parecen esfumarse la izquierda chilena
deberá buscar nuevos acuerdos con la
derecha más moderada al final a borich
no le ha quedado otra que moderar sus
planes de hecho este pasado agosto
cambió su propuesta por una que no
aumentará excesivamente los impuestos y
que logrará Elevar la recaudación en un
punto y medio del pib a través de
ciertas modificaciones legales sin
embargo Y aunque la reforma tributaria
fuera crucial para poder financiar sus
grandes planes La mayor derrota de
borich sin duda alguna fue la del
plebiscito
constitucional para quien no lo recuerde
el 4 de julio de 2022 se presentó el
proyecto de Constitución la propuesta
nacida del Consejo constitucional
constaba de
388 artículos muchísimos para una
constitución pero lo más alarmante de
todo no era su extensión sino Su
contenido aquí en Vial politic ya os
contamos Cuáles eran los principales
Pilares de ese proyecto dar un mayor
poder a los sindicatos la restricción
excesiva del despido unos derechos
sociales que no tenían mucho sentido
como el derecho universal al deporte y
medidas que claramente erosionabilidad
acabó como acabó frente al plebiscito el
gobierno quiso dar una imagen de
neutralidad pero la realidad es que
acabó convirtiéndose en la principal voz
a favor del apruebo Y sabéis qué
significó esto que el plebiscito
constitucional también se convirtió en
una especie de referéndum sobre el
gobierno de boric al final el 4 de
septiembre del 2022 el 62 por de los
chilenos rechazaron el proyecto y con
ello también en cierta forma la gestión
del presidente pero ojo porque la de
bacle del liderazgo para borich que
provocó el proceso Constituyente no
acabaría ahí el 7 de mayo del 2023 los
chilenos fueron a votar otra vez esta
vez para reconfigurar la composición del
Consejo constitucional Y adivináis qué
pasó pues fijaos terremoto político en
Chile la derecha gana con amplitud las
elecciones y tiene en sus manos la nueva
constitución el gran triunfador fue José
Antonio cast líder del partido
republicano que logró 22 de los 50
consejeros efectivamente querida
comunidad de visual politic tras el
fracaso del primer referéndum y también
de la Reforma tributaria borich perdió
el control del Consejo constitucional
frente al que fuera su contrincante en
las elecciones presidenciales el
presidente chileno No para de recibir
malas noticias no obstante si alguno
está pensando que su presidencia no
podía ir a peor nada más lejos de la
realidad chile corre el riesgo de
experimentar el auge del mismo fenómeno
que ya ha solado Ecuador en estos
últimos 2 años os estamos hablando por
supuesto de la criminalidad
atentos chile la última víctima del
crimen Seguro seguro que todos recordáis
el asesinato en Ecuador del candidato a
la presidencia Fernando villavicencio os
hemos hablado de ello aquí en viral
politic el asesinato de este candidato
es el fiel reflejo de la terrible deriva
que el pequeño país latinoamericano ha
tomado lo más impactante es que hasta
hace solo un par de años Ecuador Era uno
de los países menos violentos y
peligrosos de toda la región pero ahora
sin embargo se ha convertido en uno de
los más conflictivos y violentos bien
Pues esta misma deriva también está
llegando a Chile Es cierto que todavía
no he llegado ni de lejos a los brutales
niveles de Ecuador pero aún así la
deriva es preocupante muy preocupante
por ejemplo chile ha sido
tradicionalmente caracterizado por ser
un importante país de origen tránsito y
destino de trata de de personas en este
sentido en el país operan extensas redes
sofisticadas que buscan Víctimas de
origen asiático sobre todo de nepal y la
India y también de sus vecinos
latinoamericanos pero ahora también está
tomando mucha fuerza el tráfico ilegal
de arnas chile se está convirtiendo en
un importante mercado de compraventa una
actividad que incluso ha salpicado a los
propios cuerpos de seguridad del Estado
militares y carabineros que robaron
armas sus vínculos con bandas y narcos
quedaron registrados en la justicia
militar lo peor de todo es que el
aumento del tráfico ilegal de armas en
Chile está fuertemente relacionado con
el narcotráfico en el país y esa es la
peor noticia posible Aunque pueda
sorprenderte chile se ha convertido en
un enclave crucial para la droga
especialmente la cocaína peruana y
boliviana que se traslada a países tan
variopintos como Australia Países Bajos
o Jordania entre otros muchos a través
de importantes puertos como el de San
Antonio puerto de San Antonio es
catalogado mundialmente por la ONU como
principal punto para trasladar droga
Pues bien desde 2021 toda esta evolución
Ya se está dejando notar con el
incremento de la delincuencia en el
país de hecho si nos fijamos en el
número de homicidios y violaciones que
tuvieron lugar en 2022 nos damos cuenta
de que hubo un importante crecimiento
respecto a 2021 Hablamos de una
tendencia que no solo no se está
frenando sino que incluso podría estar
acelerándose en 2023 Y eso es lo que
explica que en abril nos encontrásemos
con esta noticia el parlamento chileno
aproba la ley que aumenta el poder de la
policía en medio de una crisis de
seguridad la normativa otorga a los
agentes más margen para la legítima
defensa y aumenta las penas para quienes
los ataquen gran parte de la nueva
izquierda de borik le dio la espalda al
artículo más controvertido exacto
queridos amigos el senado apoyó de
manera unánime la aprobación de la
conocida ley naim retamal una ley
especialmente polémica porque consagra
la legítima defensa privilegiada dicho
de otra forma que le da mayor capacidad
de decisión a los agentes y reduce la
rendición de cuentas de la policía
además junto a esta ley borich también
aprovechó para impulsar el programa
Calle sin violencia el cual eleva la
presencia de carabineros en las zonas
donde se están concentrando la mayor
parte de los delitos violentos pero por
el momento los cambios son casi
[Música]
imperceptibles ya lo veis queridos
amigos deal politic borich no ha
empezado precisamente con buen pie no ha
logrado aprobar su reforma tributaria
fracasó la opción de apruebo que apoyó
su gobierno y perdió las elecciones al
consejo constitucional la aprobación de
su presidencia está en mínimos
históricos y buena parte de los chilenos
ya le toman como un presidente ausente
casi desaparecido sí es cierto Ha
logrado impulsar alguna reforma ante la
grave crisis de inseguridad que
atraviesa el país lo cual Por cierto es
rechazado por muchos de sus votantes
pero en general la mayoría de los
analistas concuerdan en que lo que
llevamos de presidencia de Gabriel
borich esta ha sido simplemente
insustancial e irrelevante para muchos
su presidencia en cierta forma ya ha
terminado pero claro eso solo el tiempo
podrá o no confirmarlo por ahora
queremos saber vuestra opinión debería
borich adelantar elecciones Como hizo
lao en Ecuador por el bloqueo
legislativo creéis que logrará llegar a
algún acuerdo parlamentario que le
permita finalmente impulsar sus
políticas sociales podrán las medidas
adoptadas doblegar al crimen en el país
podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre no olvidéis Que
aquí en visual politics sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribios a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones echadle también
un vistazo así lo hubiera sabido Y por
supuesto si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle al botón de like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta
[Música]
pronto